sylvain n'guessan analystes politiques
ivoiriens silva une guerre sans merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors un an et demi après leur
acquittement c'est une nouvelle phase
donc de la faire laurent gbagbo et
charles blé goudé qui s'ouvre devant la
cpi à quelles sont les erreurs de
procédures dénoncées par le procureur
soulève que plusieurs procédures ont été
aurait été violée le repas était celui
sur la norme des tests de la cpi
notamment pour ce qui est de l'impact
des différents témoins qui ont pu
défiler ces quantités moi aussi je
m'amuse elle assure également n'avoir
pas reçu la copie de l'acquittement à
temps normal et donc les steeple
accoudoirs et pdci c'est différent que
c'était un but et sa voix si il faut
l'aimer mais il faut l'aider lui si le
procès donc elle appelle à une demande
et formulant qu'il des parents de passer
à la tête ou alors s'il faut les libérer
totalement donc voici un peu c'est
beaucoup et c'est des arrivées de
globull un disque avec elle alors du
coup à à l'issue un de ces de ces trois
jours de procès quels sont justement les
issues possibles prix si possible c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas de suite favorable à
la demande formulée par mme labelle
soudas est donc que l'état laurent
gbagbo charles blé goudé soit qui tu es
et tu pu se régaler le pays la côte
d'ivoire
dalet côté il ya la possibilité au style
que la cour estime que la demande
formulée par madame d'adressé mac et
donc il y a poussé un appel ce qui le
maintiendrait à bord pendant longtemps
de ce dragon ball soja blé goudé devant
là c'est plus est actuellement l'acide
attaques virulentes de la part du
président américain donald trump
il a annoncé notamment des sanctions
économiques contre des membres de la
juridiction dont fatou bensouda la
procureure ce contexte peut-il avoir une
influence ou pas sur la décision
on qui sera rendu mercredi imaginent que
après le cas de monsieur verda qui a
fait au moins huit ans d'emprisonnement
avant d'être acquitté c'est donc
l'aspect n'a pas pu réunir les preuves
le cadre c'est laurent gbagbo a
également appelé attendre novembre 2011
bientôt neuf ans a réuni également leurs
preuves cela pourrait être interprété de
différentes manières même si le
président américain joue la carte des
états unis
l'hégémonie américaine on imagine que
cela pourrait avoir des incidences sur
la décision que prendra la cour et on
espère que ce sera pour le retour du
président wade sociale doublée en quoi
tu vois afin d'apaiser davantage climat
politique justement en côte d'ivoire
quel est l'état d'esprit vous venez nous
dire que laurent gbagbo est charles blé
goudé seront à les bienvenus esséniens
stade tous les baptisés du plaisir
évidemment de telles étaient les avocats
de désaltérer en bas d'un mois avant la
présidentielle à mener et donc il pourra
jouer c'était un rôle au sein de son
parti mais aussi qu'il pourrait jouer
c'est d'un chic et politiques nationales
pour le camp d'en face j'imagine que
c'est laid pas grand chose dans la
mesure où les à laurent gbagbo pourrait
susciter une nouvelle inconnue 4 l'issue
d'élections présidentielles avez vous
parlé d'un nouveau rôle pour laurent
gbagbo
est ce qu'on peut imaginer laurent
gbagbo une nouvelle fois la tête de la
côte d'ivoire dans les années qui
viennent
c'est possible mais voilà c'est les
institutions
l'action décider de qui prennent donc
pas pour la paix 2010 n'aura pas été
condamné à 20 ans d'emprisonnement ici
donc on ne sait pas comment cette
question sera résolue
est ce que une aura une solution
politique 17 interpelle sa candidature
ou est-ce que le raf est le puck
systématiques aux droits dérivés de la
série comme le stipule la tyrie que le
cast de notre constitution j'entends
beaucoup de choses à régler mais le
souhait c'est vrai que le complot
politique puisse l'emporter sur le coup
systématique au doigt merci beaucoup
sylvain n'diaye sans avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt frange rappelle que
vous êtes analyste politique